Early on,
it seemed as if Muhammad's ambition was
simply to go from door to door,
from passion to person and say,
you know,
leave alone what you believe in.
Believe in the one God,
the one who spoke to me through the
Angel Jubril.
That's how you say it in Arabic and
Gabrielle in English
and then extort people to do certain
things that in the 21st century we
understand has religion,
prayer,
fasting congregations,
that sort of thing.
In the first 10 years in Mecca,
I would say largely harmless.
There's that Mohammed and in a very
modern way,
I don't know if you know Dr Jekyll and
Mr. Hyde,
but you could understand him as a doctor
checkup.
Then he goes to Medina and then you have
the Mr hired side of Mohammed.
Suddenly there's a militia and now he's
a politician.
He's not only preaching,
please come to the one God is demanding,
come to the one God and accept me as a
profit and if not,
I declare war and he declares war and
with a relatively small militia,
at least according to the Islamic
perception this is,
these are other Muslim documents with a
relatively small militia or a small
number of men,
he defeats a much larger,
much more well established army and that
victory leads to another victory and it
leads to another victory to another
victory.
But it also leads to complexities
because the more he gains power,
he has a say over more people and that
then leads to the necessity of
legislation.
In hindsight,
if you're in the 21st century,
you are a political scientist,
a sociologist or psychologist,
historian,
any kind of social scientist,
you look back in that time,
you agreed that matter to you will be
impressed.
You'll see goodness.
This man was great.
He defeated large armies,
he established an empire,
he legislator,
he kept them together and he left a
narrative behind that lasted many
centuries well beyond.
He was born wonderful.
Of course,
I don't argue with that.
But
what he also did was he froze his
innovation in place.
He was the last prophet.
Nobody else could come and innovate on
what he said.
In fact,
he declares innovation,
the biggest sin that I believe I can
commit,
thus the fate of the heretics of his
life.
And so if you,
if you take Muhammad's as the Steve Jobs
or you know,
the seventh century,
I want you to imagine,
I want you to think of a steve jobs
leaving a legacy behind where he says
you can never end.
You may never change the minute he finds
himself on his deathbed,
never change
the iphone four or the IPAD air,
I forget which condition these things
were back then or the mark.
So that's Tim Cook would never have,
he would only have one thing which would
be to continue it and to say these are
timeless and that's pretty much what
Muhammad did.
The Koran is a timeless document.
His example is rendered timeless and I
think that is a disservice that Mohammed
did to his own innovation.
His great achievement was the fact that
he managed.
If,
if,
if that narrative,
again,
that narrative is a contested narrative,
but if that narrative is true,
his greatest innovation was to unite the
Arabs,
make them transcend themselves,
unites into a super tribe and conquer.
But the biggest mistake he then made
would be to freeze things in place.
And that is the curse of Islam.
Is this
the fact that innovation is a sin,
innovation is a bad thinking.
They close the gates freezer.
That is the curse of it.
That's the firewall to Islamic thinking.
And we can see the result in everyday
life.
Again,
I repeat.
It's a perception of the people who put
these beliefs into practice.
What really happened is still a massive
study.
Okay.